I could be helpful ah screw it the max
this series was one of the things that
completely blew open my mind in terms of
what can be done with animation I saw it
around the same time that I saw Ralph
Bochy's Wizards and the resulting
one-two punch really cemented that my
love of animation was not going to fade
as I crossed the threshold of
adolescence and entered into adulthood
so how does one describe the max I'm not
asking that rhetorically I genuinely
have no idea I suppose bizarre would be
the word of the day everything from the
ourselves the plot it's all very
experimental it's borderline stream of
consciousness but it does sort of follow
this internal logic so it's weird as
heck but it's not weird for just the
sake of being weird which keeps it from
being as pretentious as it really could
have ended up being superficially it's a
superhero story or at least it starts
out as one there's a costumed hero
there's a damsel there's a villa in
reality it's about family ties spirit
animals astral projections dreams versus
reality and emotional suppression just
to mention a few of the major themes so
given how difficult the stories to
describe I suppose we'll talk about the
animation style and there really is
nothing else like this a lot of the
artwork was quite literally scanned from
Sam Keith's original comic book pages
but it doesn't mean that it's like those
motion comics that's kind of get put out
every now and then there's some real
dynamic animation going on now whenever
you do something in animation the more
details there are and something the
harder it is to make it move and make it
look good when it does so the way the
show maintains the integrity of some
incredibly highly detailed images is by
only animating a few select parts of the
image now that keeps it from becoming
overly static the most common example
would be a character who's speaking and
overall they're not moving but their
eyes are squinting and adjusting in
their mouth is moving but the rest of
the highly detailed images left pretty
much there another fairly prominent
example is the female character may be
standing pose but her hair is waving
behind her in the wind and sort of
keeping that steady motion doesn't ever
make it feel like you're just looking at
a static page or an image that isn't
moving it's sort of the way that
balances
maintain is because so few elements are
actually in motion it means they were
able to put a lot of work and effort
into making sure the ones that were
moving look amazing and look as good as
the stuff that's saying still if they
are trying to animate every single
aspect of the character the way the way
they animate these select elements they
never would have had the time or the
money to do it another way they come
back the static frame issues just by
really clever use of the camera mainly
in the form of pans you'll have the
camera slowly move across an image and
just revealing more as it goes as a
character is talking and it keeps it
from feeling locked off but then at the
same time doesn't require the extra time
effort and money required to actually
animate the characters moving all that
much because the camera gives that
feeling of movement it's a technique you
extra see all the time and animate but
off the top my head I can't think of a
Western animated film that has borrowed
that technique but has zero anime
influence in the art style now I'm a fan
of the comic book as well although I saw
the animated show first but I actually
think that the n main show works better
in some respects than the comic book
does particularly when it comes to
flashing back and forth between sort of
the real world and the dream world of
the outback there's one shot which burns
so strongly into my memory when I first
saw it it's still amazing it's this
incredibly long slow pan across the city
and they'll just be flashes of it
becoming the Outback so like for
instance you'll pan across and you'll
see this is father heavy guy in a chair
with his kids crawling all over and
suddenly it'll flash to a carcass with
scavengers gnawing on authentic flashes
back to reality again as the camera
continues to pan it's an amazing shot
and it just integrates these two worlds
and draws the parallels better than the
comic book page did then there are the
characters who are as unique as the
artwork max himself he is a really hero
he's more just kind of a schlub and he
knows he has to protect Julie winters
but he doesn't really understand how and
he hasn't even bothered to question why
Julie herself is gorgeously flawed
ultimately this really is much more her
story than it is Max's and she's a very
well-rounded and very complicated
character it is all
quite refreshing that she isn't drawn as
the physical ideal there's a tension
brought a number of times to a slight
gut that she has that she probably wish
wasn't there but the way the images are
drawn there's still a love of her form
of her more realistically proportioned
body and that's just really nice to see
and then there's mr. gone who is the de
facto villain of the piece and beyond
just an amazing design which is across
the board on this thing but the voice
work done by the late Barry Stigler is
beyond compare this is a character who
likes to talk and he does it a lot and
he could have very easily been boring or
even grading in the hands of the wrong
voice actor but I never get tired of
hearing him talk which is a good thing
because he serves as narrator at various
points across the show gone is also an
interesting villain because he really
blurs lions in terms of how much of a
villain he really is I mean he's a bad
person there's really no question about
that but at the same time he is offering
more guidance and more insight to Julie
and what she's going through than anyone
else in the story and it's a very
complicated very fascinating dynamic
this is the sort of show that I wish I
could recommend to everybody but I'm
good conscious I can't because it's just
too weird and some people they're just
gonna be turned off by how strange this
thing is however I'll say this if you
have a love of animation eyes on art
form and you haven't seen this before
watch the first 30 minutes which is
roughly the first two episodes if you
feel it's too weird for you at that
point you can walk away and still feel
confident that you've experienced the
visual uniqueness that is the max but
who knows maybe those 30 minutes will
hook you the way that they hooked me and
you'll dig this thing from start to
finish so were you around for the days
when MTV got into experimental animation
the era that gave us the max because it
also gave us things like aeon flux the
head even the first incarnation of
beavis and butt-head if you were around
and saw any of these what was your
favorite of that kind of error and realm
of television whatever it is drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it as for me I'll be back as
soon as I can get my next fix